indeed after one of those miniatures
only lasting about 18 moves
well more like 148 moves
we are with begging that game was
titanic it looked like
you had an easy win and then the whole
thing flipped yeah
i did wrong at some point i saw that
knight c3 and b4 i should be totally
winning
and i couldn't find the right move i
guess and then it got so tricky i got so
frustrated i said okay probably let's
draw again like and then i
decided i need to fight and find ideas
there
so at some point i should be winning
very easily you dropped the a pawn that
was the the main problem
i didn't see what to do if i play uh
rook bivon i guess i could play rick
pimen right
the position oh we can get the position
back you remember yaz when she plays
queen eight check she allowed queen
eight but
so i shouldn't take on uh should not
take on d5 rook being on right instead
a3 simply
d5 and now rook b1
a3 no i think rook b1 was the winning
move yeah wait uh what's the difference
eight read and uh like white can take on
a3 oh this is not we had rook b1 earlier
i was pretty sure it was work b1 that
was when you were b1 no we have it we
have it on the asteroid's board actually
one as
yeah that was actually
my initial idea but i wasn't sure if
it's winning after
uh
after
like knight e5
i guess
95 rook c7 i think was the win move
because if i take on d if two then d6 i
i didn't find the right right move here
i guess i wasn't sure what to do after i
think the much more difficult question
was if she goes d6 after queen to b8
and i have a feeling there is only one
move in the screen and that is queen f8
i saw this move but i wasn't sure what
to do after uh knight e5
i didn't see rook c7 i missed it so
let's go back to the 95 variation
i wasn't sure if i played uh
[Music]
rook c7
yeah i didn't see this one
and then just push the pawn
apparently also just taking on f2
although it works c7 looks like the
safest taking on f2 saving the pawn this
way and then queen back down to b2
will be yeah
and rook g rook takes on g2 right
yeah
at some point and then
i think d6 queen b2 that might be a
that's an important line d6 queen b2 and
if queen g5 now you can just simply take
on g2 yeah
i don't know why my initial idea was to
play rook b1 and after the time control
i start the thing and i did just pull
[ __ ]
then then you got into this titanic
struggle that looked just like it was
drawn but slowly but surely she started
giving you real chances yeah uh
like i tricked her in the end i was like
okay
this this is this should work you know
and rook after rook g8 it's just all
same position i guess i i'm not sure
it's still hard to very hard to win that
game but well somehow you traded queens
like right here sorry back up you guys
right here you traded
you managed to trade queens we had a
trick queen before instead of queen b6
yeah was a good move because of knight
f3 and okay she missed rook g5 idea she
did and then you got to this end game
where you still should have been drawn
you seem to just get life after life
after life i just tried my best i knew
that it must like it had to be many and
i missed it and i was like okay fine
whatever i need to continue playing you
know you gave your coach a heart attack
[Laughter]
well indeed a titanic struggle you get a
rest day with three rounds to go who do
you have remaining i have no idea
i i i don't know who i'm playing with
i just check it after the round all
right right attitude congrats on this
win you deserve some rest go get it
thank you very much well done what a
fight what a fight and what a day yeah
first she had to force the traitor
queens not easy not easy that was